bonjour à tous vous le savez évidemment
il ya quelques jours roland garros a
refermé ses portes et avec une édition
historique puisque rafael nadal a
remporté son huitième titre chez les
hommes et rentrer un peu plus dans
l'histoire du tennis mondial dans le
handisport dans le tournoi tennis
fauteuil c'est le français stéphane
houdet numéro 2 mondial qui a remporté
son deuxième titre porte d'auteuil dans
le tennis handisport français cette fois
ci il y à un jeune espoir du tennis qui
fait ses gammes en ce moment qui joue
depuis à peu près six ans et nous sommes
avec johan guillou bonjour à vous
bonjour vous êtes licencié donc le
tennis-club de la période juillet un des
terrains jeu je le disais vous êtes un
espoir une valeur montante du tennis
handisport français puisque vous êtes
rentré il ya quelques semaines dans le
top 40 mondial après six années de
pratique votre progression fulgurante
c'est ça ouais voilà j'ai commencé comme
vous dites si bien le tennis fauteuil il
ya maintenant six ans avec une
progression fulgurante puisque j'ai
commencé j'étais après classés 3
centièmes et aujourd'hui depuis la
semaine dernière en revenant dans le
tournoi de flushing meadows à new york
je suis maintenant placer la 35e place
mondiale ce qui laisse espérer
beaucoup d'espoir sur les années à venir
et pourquoi pas
sélectionné pour les prochains jeux de
rio 2016 les journaux ont parlé un petit
peu un petit peu plus tard vous le
disiez vous avez progressé de façon
fulgurante joueur de 3e série en 2009
champion de france de 3e série en 2010
puis de 2e série cette année il ya des
titres qui se ramassent à la pelle
comment vous fait quel est votre secret
mon secret je crois que c'est vraiment
déjà que j'ai c'est une vraie passion ce
sport j'ai commencé donc enfin passionné
par commencé en loisir et puis c est
vite devenu une passion leur envie de
faire de la compétition
de rien lâché et en faite le
comment j'y suis arrivé à voir tous ces
titres de champion de france dans les
séries inférieures c'est que tout
simplement c'est le travail
l'acharnement la passion c'est
m'entraîner 6 7 heures par semaine après
mon mes journées travail c'est de faire
du coaching physique avoir un coach
mental vraiment une vraie structure pour
me permettre de pouvoir grimper et
évoluer au niveau du tennis mondial
handisport vous êtes dans le tennis
handisport depuis six ans donc là vous
avez 27 ans comme je le disais six ans
avant vous faisiez quoi vous pratiquiez
déjà le tennis en tant que valide non
non non malheureusement j'aurais bien
voulu ce que j'aurai au moins j'aurais
pu acquérir la technique mais non avant
j'étais je faisais du sport mais dans un
autre secteur qui était le football tout
simplement comment vous est venue alors
du coup au tennis fauteuil alors c'est
je cherchais une activité handisport
puisque pour moi pour moi ça prend une
place très importante dans ma vie
malheureusement c'est pas évident de
trouver une section handisport ou des
associations et on n'a pas non plus dans
toutes les villes et j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer monsieur blanchet daniel
qui a donc j'ai qui est président de
l'association en bouillie handisport
là il m'a proposé plusieurs activités
notamment le tennis et au bout d'une
heure il m'a invité et c'est tout de
suite su que c'était ça allait devenir
mon sport favori
comme je le disais vous vous jouez en 10
sport en tennis fauteuil depuis six ans
puisqu'en fait vous êtes amputé depuis
l'âge de 18 ans car vous souffrez d'un
ostéosarcome alors expliquez-moi un
petit peu ce que c'est alors j'ai été
amputée effectivement l'âge de 18 ans à
la suite d'un ostéosarcome mais ça avait
déjà commencé à l'âge de mes 15 ans
alors un ostéosarcome un cancer des os
moi ça s'est focalisé sur ma jambe
droite au niveau de mon genou et mon
fémur et malheureusement trois ans après
donc à mes 18 ans le cancer des os est
revenu avec métastases donc j'étais
vraiment entre la vie et la mort les
médecins de nos des six mois de six mois
de survie
est en fait il ya une sorte de force en
soi qui fait qu' on se dit mais non j'ai
pas envie d'en rester là et
la vie la vie est belle il faut
continuer et je me suis accroché bon bah
c'est passé par la perte de ma jambe
et également de multiples opérations
puisque j'ai d'autres d'autres organes
qui ont été touchés mais voilà c'est une
maladie comme les autres et faut faire
face et je me suis toujours dit il faut
aller de l'avant c'est de cette maladie
vous avez tiré cette force et on va dire
cette rage de vaincre pour gagner ces
titres à l'heure actuelle ouais ouais
tout à fait cette maladie elle m'a fait
extrêmement g jakiri acquiert acquérir
une certaine maturité
une certaine force du courage et puis
c'est surtout qu'on est passés par des
périodes très difficiles avec ma famille
est ce qui fait que ce qui fait que
j'avais déjà franchi un pas énorme dans
la vie alors que j'avais seulement 18
ans et effectivement c'est une vraie
force aujourd'hui il est passé dans ces
étapes là à l'âge de 21 ans donc vous
découvrez le tennis qu'est ce que ça
vous procure depuis six ans ce sport qui
est si exigeant en fin de compte au
quotidien en fait ça me procure comme je
disais voilà du vrai plaisir et en même
temps puis je monte dans la compétition
plus j'ai besoin de vraiment de
structurer mon projet c'est devenu
vraiment je le considère comme presse
comme un projet professionnel où je suis
moi même le chef de projet c'est à dire
à la fois dans la gestion de mes
entraînements dans la gestion de mon
coaching mantin dans la gestion au
coaching physique est également dans la
gestion de mes partenaires de mon budget
voilà c'est vraiment une sorte de micro
entreprises que je gère et c'est ça qui
me passionne c'est que j'arrive à
compléter en plus de mon activité
professionnelle je suis quelqu'un
d'assez actifs voilà c'est vraiment ce
qui me ce qui me plaît quand il ya les
résultats c'est encore mieux quoi et
cette micro-entreprise on va dire
qu'elle se porte bien puisque là vous
venez d'intégrer il ya quelques semaines
le top 40 mondial là vous êtes 35e un
joueur mondial comment vous faites
justement pour vous dire voilà je suis
35e mais je vais encore aller plus loin
et mon objectif principal c'est dans
trois ans et les jeux olympiques de rio
voilà ce que je me dis c'est qu'on lâche
rien on est sur la bonne voie faut
encore multiplier les efforts je suis
quelqu'un qui s'arrête jamais
je vais toujours aller de l'avant voilà
je suis pas je me dis payet sait à qui
on va en rester là non voilà il me reste
encore des saisons comme vous l'avez dit
trois ans devant moi j'ai une saison
2013 a terminé j'ai encore des
entraînements j'ai encore énormément de
choses à apprendre au niveau de mon
tennis et au niveau de ma personnalité
surtout au niveau du mental parce qu'il
faut savoir quand même que le mental
c'est quand même 50 % chez les joueurs
valides et handisports c'est la même
chose donc comment ce que ça me procure
c'est que j'ai vraiment envie de
continuer m'accrocher au maximum pour
pour aller plus loin possible et jeux
olympiques vers ces jeux olympiques qui
en plus on se passait à rio c'est quand
même un endroit magique et j'ai envie
d'y être tout simplement vous avez pris
en quelque sorte départ d'un marathon
depuis depuis dix mois parce que là
quatre ans c'est long ça peut paraître
peut-être trop long non non non c'est
pas trop long je pense que voilà comme
je vous le disais moi je suis pas issu
du tennis valide donc quatre ans c'est
vraiment parfait pour moi pour me
préparer le mieux possible pour pour ces
jeux après ce qui est aussi difficile
pour moi c'est que j'ai une activité
professionnelle à gérer à côté
donc c'est vraiment presque un double
défi pour moi
après voilà je pense que on verra
peut-être sur les années à venir
peut-être qu'une arène d'année
sabbatique ou un aménagement plus
conséquent on aménagements de temps de
travail de mon temps de travail sera
chaud que j'ai passés par là en fait
pour continuer à progresser conquérir le
graal effectivement alors cette
qualification pour les jeux olympiques
de 2016 il ya un cahier des charges il
faut faire partie du top 40 mondial
peut-être top 30 mais aussi faire partie
des quatre meilleurs joueurs français et
là il ya embouteillage comme on dit
puisque stéphane houdet numéro deux il y
à nicolas peifer frédéric cattaneo et g
michaël jeremiasz au city numéro 9
mondial il ya du monde il ya du beau
monde il ya du beau monde mais voilà
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure ça fait
que six ans que j'ai commencé le tennis
six ans que je progresse puisque jacques
guéry la 35e place mondiale la semaine
dernière il me reste trois ans devant
moi ces joueurs certes ont un très bon
niveau mais je suis conscient de mes
capacités je crois en moi je crois mon
staff je crois en mes coaches je crois
en tout mes partenaires qui me
soutiennent et j'ai envie de dire que
voilà je suis calme actuellement numéro
7 français placement international donc
je suis juste derrière ces joueurs là il
me reste trois places à prendre et je
pense que tout est jouable pour obtenir
non une place le billet le billet pour
rio pour les jeux dans quatre ans
comment vous pensez que vous pouvez la
voir c'est ce billet il ya quel domaine
du jeu vous devez encore travailler
alors moi ce que ce que je sais que je
dois travailler c'est surtout au niveau
stratégique est également la technique
j'ai un corps j'ai encore des besoins de
travailler sur tout
mon revers la strate des dieux la montée
au filet on va dire qu'ils n'ont rien pu
sur un jeu d'attaqué comme stéphane
houdet puisqu'on a quasiment le même on
a le même handicap et je pense que j'ai
la puissance de son jeu et c'est un
modèle pour moi puisque c'est un jeu qui
lui permet de gagner au jour
d'aujourd'hui et moi j'ai vu que ça
faisait preuve si donc on va continuer
dans ce sens là sur chaque saison cet
investissement ça représente un coût
évidemment être joueur de tennis
professionnel c'est un budget par saison
votre votre budget type pour une saison
il est de l'île et de quel ordre alors
le budget type et de à peu près trente
mille euros depuis deux ans j'ai
commencé avec des saisons avec un budget
moindre puisque je faisais plus des
tournois nationaux maintenant je suis
quand même amené à faire des tournois
international sur les quatre continents
je pars régulièrement quasiment tous les
mois donc effectivement il ya une grosse
partie pour les voyages et les tournants
à l'étranger une partie pour justement
le tennis la technique ce soit mentale
tennis tennistique et physique est
également une partie pour ce qui est de
l'équipement équipant du fauteuil comme
vous voyez ici ça fait deux mois que je
lai comme un fauteuil qui est un coût
puisque sa voisine et 6000 euros est
également le coût des raquettes et d
des vêtements du textile en quelque
sorte vous avez une vie de professionnel
tout en étant amateur c'est à peu près
ça c'est un peu ça c'est ça aussi qui me
réjouit c'est que je cette sensation
c'est vraiment je vis un peu la même
chose que joueur professionnel
j'en fais pas mon métier je sais que
c'est sûr quelques années mais voilà je
me fais plaisir et et moi en tout cas je
le considère comme professionnel puisque
comme je disais tout à l'heure au début
d'émission j'en suis vraiment le presque
le chef de projet et c'est ce qui me
plaît aussi
dans cette activité sportive jeu merci
nous avoir accordé un petit peu d'entre
deux entraînements parce que je sais que
vous allez repartir dans quelques jours
en tournois à l'étranger bon courage et
vous savez tout ce qu'on vous souhaite
un pour la suite de la saison et
peut-être dans quelques années pour pour
rio merci beaucoup merci à vous quant à
moi je me retrouve dans quelques minutes
pour la suite du 7-8 sport avec les
jeunes footballeurs du club de plaisir
après leur finale de coupe des yvelines
mais avant je vous propose de partir à
la rencontre du pilote de formule 1
charles pic le français était de passage
ce week-end à saint quentin en yvelines
et patrick jacques de dixmude l'a suivi
des pneus deux fois plus large et un
aileron aérodynamique digne d'une
formule 1 la twizy de charles pic n'a
plus grand chose à voir avec le petit
modèle électrique qui sillonnent saint
quentin en yvelines le véhicule a même
été équipée pour l'occasion du caire ce
système de turbo qui permettent aux
formules 1 d'avoir une puissance
supplémentaire en phase d'accélération
et quand les 445 kilos monte en régime
et bien cela patine un petit peu
elle marche très bien c'était là la
première fois que j'essayais bon il ya
un gars à l'intérieur donc c'est c'est
sûr que là il faut faire attention parce
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de puissance que
que ce qu'il faudrait mais non c'est ce
sera ça va évidemment les fans de f1
n'aurait pas louper cet arrêt au stand
saint quentinois bon à la formule 1
c'est pour moi c'est un rêve ça a
toujours été une passion pour moi et le
fait d'avoir à charles pic aujourd'hui
en piste au pied de chez moi vous c'est
vrai que ça en événements et je pouvais
pas rater ça donc je suis super content
d'avoir un autographe de sa part est
aussi une photo donc je souhaite
beaucoup bonne chance pour la suite de
la saison le pilote français devrait
d'ailleurs bénéficier d'améliorations
sur sa voiture pour les prochains grands
prix c'est ma deuxième saison en f1 donc
j'ai une saison d'expérience
pour à titre d'exemple par exemple
l'année dernière je découvrais la moitié
des pistes qu'il y avait à peu près une
piste sur deux que je connaissais pas la
stanley je les connais tout donc c'est
sûr que oui je suis je suis plus à l'est
cette année avant de rouler en
électrique charles pic aimerait marquer
ses premiers points cette saison
peut-être au grand prix de silverstone
en grande-bretagne le 30 juin prochain